a huge March snaked through the center
of La Paz on Thursday almost certainly
the biggest since discontent began over
Bolivia's elections where protesting
because they don't respect our vote or
democracy the anger and numbers on the
streets appeared to increase after
President Evo Morales said that he was
the outright winner of the Bolivian
elections we won the first round
electoral authorities later confirmed
his win but there's doubt over that vote
and not just from these protesters the
European Union and the Organization of
American States also voiced concerns
especially about an almost 24-hour
freezing of the rapid vote count just
when it indicated that this was going to
a second round when the count came back
online Morales was suddenly heading for
an outright first round win on Thursday
a usually fragmented opposition United
around Carlos Meza the leading
challenger to Morales as well pretty
mayor of the coordination and defense of
democracy resolves to first go first
second election around administered in a
peaceful and impartial way second to
call on citizens social organizations
and institutions to continue to hold
peaceful rallies until the vote is
respected many still support president
Morales he was the favorite going into
the election partly thanks to wealth
distribution programs that have almost
half poverty he called this a coup and
chided the Organization of American
States for questioning the process I
don't want to think that OAS mission is
already taking part in the coup d'etat I
don't know if they understood me
yesterday the OAS as a whole should
evaluate themselves and the mission it
sent as well president Morales hasn't
really addressed the main criticism here
that almost 24-hour gap between results
instead he's hit
accusing candidate Carlos Meza of being
a criminal and saying that the young
people protesting against him have been
paid with money or with better grades we
put that two students on the March it's
disrespectful to say that to the
universities and the students he's
trying to minimize our vote they haven't
paid us or given us grades this is
actually affecting us because this week
we had exams with protest strikes or
burning of public buildings in many of
Bolivia's departments the crisis is if
anything deepening john hoeven
al jazeera la paz
[Applause]